are we good with a camera okay so it's a
pleasure to welcome max Bergman see
who's going to talk about from you oh
you see is going to talk about
compositional properties of statistical
procedures looking for that thanks
Moritz and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and for some inexplicable
reason asking me to make everybody
suffer for an hour so I'm gonna talk
about a very classical top decision
procedure statistical decision
procedures and this is you know
essentially what everybody in statistics
and machine learning is doing you take
data which are generated by some random
mechanism and you map it to a decision
in machine learning a decision is
typically a function that allows you to
make predictions on fresh samples from
the same mechanism in classical
statistics the decision is something
about the supposed supposed parameter of
the population that the data came from
but either way it's it's a statistical
decision procedure it's a function from
data to some action and in these days
we've heard and we've heard many talks
about adaptive composition when
essentially you have a sequential
process where let's hope from now on I'm
gonna use s to do no data sample like
typically you know think about think
about a tuple of iid samples from some
unknown distribution and that's your
data and a statistical decision
procedure would take that possibly
randomized manner generate some action W
and again I'm paying dues to you know
the smarter and viewpoint that neural
networks are gonna take over and so the
only decisions I make are about you know
weights and the neural networks that you
know right so this is a this is a
typical any statistical decision
procedure looks like this however if you
look in the guts of the statistical
decision procedure it actually consists
of little incremental steps typically
because that's how we build things this
is how I engineer things right we take
little building blocks and we compose
them together so really what might be
happening is there could be some initial
action w1 then you have another step
that looks at the data this a typically
the same
and a w1 and generates w2 and then of
course you know if you have these
multi-step decision procedures the next
thing might actually look at the data
and at w1 and @ w2 and generate w3 right
and then you keep going and at some
point you stop and let's say you know it
depends on the context you might just
take the final point like final let's
say wwt right so these arrows going from
everything to it and from the data or
you might actually take some subsequence
it is because you know somehow you
wanted to do this kind of multi
hypothesis testing or whatever you know
you so you might take a subset of these
and then of course the question is if we
know so this is how we you know think
about this problem from a viewpoint of
somebody who designs these things
typically you know the way you choose
these building blocks is because they've
been tested previously you know their
properties at each of these building
blocks is something that in isolation
you understand really well but once you
compose these things knowing these local
properties of the building block what
blocks what can you say about end-to-end
performance of the statistical procedure
and you know all these all these recent
works on what's called adaptive
composition this is exactly what what
these words call it out of the adaptive
composition law from you you point out
it's a classical statistician and what
is it what are you adapting to here
right typically adaptation is you know
you have some unknown smoothness
parameter you know in a so blowing ball
you don't know you don't know the
constant you don't know the radius some
like that you adapt to that
automatically from the you pointed
classical statistics there's not a
patient here there is at a patient
however because what you're doing is
you're adapting to sort of past past
decisions in some sense right so but the
terminology is there so you know this is
called let's go to adaptive composition
and when you describe this whole thing
by
a composition of what you call
essentially markup kernels right fancy
fancy speak because if this is a
randomized procedure of each of these
the randomized procedure then
essentially what you have is you have I
have call it something like this you
know if you want to be all fancy it's a
it's it's a collection of probability
measures on your action space and this
collection is indexed by the data and
the syntax thing is is done in a
measurable way meaning that if I were to
essentially ask a question like okay if
I fix s then this would be a probability
distribution on your action space for
any s but on the other hand if I fix a
so suppose a is a subset of my action
space and I look at this function it's a
function from data into probabilities
this function has to be measurable right
so so that that at the very least you'll
be able to take expectations with
respect to the distribution of s but
then when you when you form this
adaptive composition or composition what
you're doing is you're composing these
mark of kernels in the following way
you have now we have a distribution
indexed by the same data set what the
distribution is over to all of these
decisions and it's a product right it's
um so essentially at each time T what
you do is you take your algorithm or
procedure that use at that time and the
other thing is that this also has
dependence on all previous decisions
that you made or at least in principle
may depend on all of them and so this is
and so you're interested in the
properties of this Joint Distribution
index by the data set right so in
particular you know one thing you might
actually be interested in at the very
least is if you marginalize out
everything except for W capital T right
so marginalize out everything except
the last decision what can we say about
this right
so why do we care about this because
let's suppose that and now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna just call this
just W so W is the last stage in my in
my compositional structure so one thing
you might be interested in is something
like bias right this is a question about
generalization right so so you typically
would have some sort of a function so
again we said that s is is a tuple
typically iid from some distribution and
so you might have a function L of W and
Z so it's a loss of action W when the
observation takes value Z and then you
of course might take the expectation so
if if these Z's are iid according to
some distribution mu you might be
interested in call it L of W or Elm U of
W it's the expected value right
of this with respect to the true data
generating mechanism but on the other
hand if you don't know this mu which is
typically the situation and machine
learning statistics the best you can do
is well one of the things you can do is
compute the empirical loss and this
simply is Meg denoted by L sub s and
it's simply it's it's also an
expectation but with respect to the
empirical distribution it's denoted by
this mu hat s Z right and you have as
disease simply the you know it's it's
the average of Dirac Delta's sitting at
the data points all right then and and
and this is a kind of a classic thing
right so there's no integral here of
course because that's a expectation
respected average of direct measure is
sitting in the samples right then and
then and then the question of
quantifying bias or or generalization or
however you might call it is now if s
and W are related through this
statistical decision procedure if I were
to so if I were to look at for fixed W
obviously I look at this L of W and the
expectation of this with respect to the
data is equal to precisely that right
this is unbiased for any fixed W or even
for any random W that's independent of
the data however if if s and W are
related through this mechanism the
procedure then you know we know that in
fact expected value of L of W minus LS
of W is not 0 in fact in general it's
gonna be if you're doing something like
M estimation this thing is gonna be
non-negative
because M estimators tend to be
negatively biased so we want to get
estimates on the stick and this is where
the issue of stability comes in right
and we've heard mean he talks about
stability stability essentially means
that
if in a sense the decision w ultimately
does not depend too much any individual
coordinate of the data set yes then we
can expect that somehow you would you
would get some sort of concentration of
this and and the way to think about this
is to think classic concentration to
measure if you have a function of a
bunch of independent random objects and
it doesn't depend too sensitively on any
of them in particular then this function
will tend to be constant with high
probability right that's the high
dimensional concentration phenomenon we
expect something like that here except
of course the the the the tricky thing
here is that what we're looking at is a
distribution valued function from a
product space right into space of
measures on your on your actions so how
can we quantify stability well one of
the one of the ways in which you could
do this is is you could say alright so
let me look at this I look at this
distribution index by s and imagine some
other data set s Prime I mean this is
all well known some other s bar data set
as bar where let's say I can compute the
Hamming distance between s and s bar and
it's simply the number of coordinates in
which the corresponding samples disagree
and if this and if this mapping is let's
say so I suppose I can come up with some
sort of a distance on on distributions
and I could argue that this is Lipschitz
then you could say that C measures the
sensitivity of my algorithm decision
procedure to local modifications in the
data and from this I could presumably
infer the I couldn't for some sort of
property of this bias so this doesn't
have to be as a metric you know recent
notions that we have seen in in the
literature replace this with some sort
of an information theoretic measure of
similarity or dissimilarity between
distributions for example something like
relative entropy so you could look at
all Beck library divergence
let's say it's less than some epsilon go
up so you know C is typically something
Effect 1 or 2 or whatever in Epsilon
it's typically small right there's just
so so this is just called and there are
various names I think the name and one
more more recent papers is max KL
stability or something like this or you
could look at differential privacy
differential privacy is a way of
essentially relating this to hypothesis
tests and differential privacy would
mean something like this if the Hamming
distance between s and s prime is equal
to s bar is equal to 1 then you could
say something like this for any
measurable set a in your hypothesis
space you have something like this e to
the Delta yes for any e to the epsilon
plus plus Delta right so and and
actually
this can be also related in terms of
something called a gamma divergence
which I'm not gonna go into but but you
could you can relate this in terms of
divergence okay so all of these things
somehow lead to statements about the
expected value of this and you expect
that you know the smaller this epsilon
the smaller the smaller this is now the
question is of K if you start composing
these things and you can say something
about the properties stability
properties of each piece how stable all
the whole overall arrangement be and
this is a question that you know in fact
you know if you abstract from from the
statistical nature of this this is a
question that say engineers ask all the
time if I you know compose a bunch of
building blocks nine each of them
doesn't mess things up too much at what
point does the whole arrangement come
crashing down and and I have to redesign
things right and it's actually a very
complicated question you can think about
so you know how can you quantify this
there are these questions about let's
say what's called adaptive composition
so let's suppose in each of these pieces
is let's say epsilon stable in some
sense and I start accumulating this how
does this stability deteriorate well in
most cases if you choose your things
reasonably well it deteriorates linearly
meaning that you know somehow if each
piece is epsilon stable you go through t
rounds the the whole arrangement would
be T T epsilon stable you can do better
sometimes and
and again it's actually a very very
complicated question even if I know
something about each of these pieces
what can I say about the whole
arrangement so since we've heard many
many talks about you know differential
privacy and an adaptive composition you
know stable medians etc I figure you
know I won't say I won't be able to add
anything to that work what I want to
talk about is it very very actually you
know it's the fact that an algorithm or
procedure that we use all the time or
two two procedures that we use all the
time
are in fact compositional in nature and
you know we can begin to understand
compositional properties by looking at
these algorithms and I'm talking about
two things MCMC and gradient descent
stochastic gradient descent in
particular
and also very even though you don't
think of them as compositions you know
you might even think about them as just
you know gradient descent is like this
primitive it's it's something that just
there you run it and it does things but
it's actually composition moreover
conditioned on on on the data s
stochastic gradient descent is a Markov
chain with constant step size it's
actually a time homogeneous Markov chain
Markov chain Monte Carlo by its very
name is also Markov chain so we might
you know get somewhere with that and and
now even though my my my talk title has
the word information theory in it using
information theory sometimes is not the
most useful thing for example a lot of
recent works started looking at ok so
here's so let's suppose let's forget
about the compositional structure for
now we have this stochastic mechanism
that Maps data to to an action you can
look at the following things you can
look at let's say Shannon mutual
information
between S&W and and remember since s is
a tuple if you can control this number
you could say something about about the
bias right so there's a recent work by
so-and-so and a follow-up work by my now
former student audience Shu
this will be presented at nips by
audience if
the loss LW Z so here Z Z comes from Z
is a distribution of an individual
coordinate in your data set and W here
is is an arbitrary deterministic
hypothesis if this is Sigma so Gaussian
for each W then the absolute value of
the expected difference between so this
is the population risk or the expected
risk of the hypothesis or the action
returned by your procedure - its
empirical proxy so this is the found on
no bias this is smaller than square root
of 2 Sigma squared divided by n times
the mutual information between the input
and the output
so this mutual information is small in
particular if it's constant then you
know that then you're doing okay but you
know but but in general you might you
might aim for something like
it scales the number of samples but
scales you know at a moderate rate so
then you see that in fact you get bias
is gonna be on the order of squared
epsilon and that's actually a very weak
guarantee this mutual information
because for example things like
differential privacy or max scale
stability are generally much stronger
requirements on the algorithm than the
neutral information you know an earlier
result that let's see so this this was
me Sasha Rockland maths our hoo-hoos now
he was an undergrad at the time he's now
a grad student at at Stanford
Hong Wu who used to be at Illinois now
he's at Yale and and our lean this was
presented 16 we considered a different
measure of stability what's that okay
let's let's consider the following let's
let's look at the classic notion of
stability that that was proposed by mu C
and L SAF in the context of learning
they said suppose I have a learning
algorithm right so or a decision
procedure right and then and this is
actually remember that this s is a two
pole and and suppose I told you I hid
let's say I randomly picked an index
from one to N and I hid that example a
training example I told you everything
else and I told you the hypothesis
returned by the algorithm how much would
you know about that one example that I
hid so if on average this knowledge that
you gain from even knowing most of the
data set except one element and the
hypothesis is not enough to pin down
that example well then you know that
then you can expect stability they
phrase that in terms of expected losses
or empirical losses but you can phrase
that also in terms of conditional mutual
informations so so would say that
suppose that so this is what happens I
pick a coordinate uniformly at random
and ask you a question how much knowing
the hypothesis and so here I'm using
notation Z minus I to denote every
except for the ice coordinate how much
do you know about the night coordinate
so this quantity is small they would say
that this is stable in what's called
erasure mutual information this quantity
on on this sum is actually this has a
name it's denoted by I minus W and s and
it's called the erasure mutual
information was introduced by surgery
overdue in sake Wiseman in a paper hold
information lost in erasures and in fact
you've seen the talk by tom lanka on
tuesday where he talked about on average
leave one out kale stability or
something like that this is exactly this
notion so we showed that in fact on
there slightly different conditions here
you know in order not to make things too
technical you can assume that the loss
function is bounded and of loss function
is bounded by 0 and 1 then in that case
the bias is upper bounded by well
constant
some constant depending on how you
evaluate things times epsilon right so
this is this again is a
it's you can show that this erasure
mutual information is smaller than
mutual information - something else and
so if mutual information so it's a
weaker criterion if your mutual
information stable then you know then
you're gonna be epsilon stable with
respect to the ratio mutual information
so so you can and you can and you can
actually compute these things and show
stability in the sense for a variety of
algorithms for example one algorithm
which this in which this can be verified
you know very cleanly is what's called
the Gibbs strategy right the Gibbs
strategy is give strategy is when you
when you pick a prior so your
distribution on the hypothesis given the
data is proportional to some prior on
the hypothesis space times e to the
minus beta LS W so beta here is the
temperature parameter and then you can
you can crank it up and you can show
that in fact all reasonable definitions
of stability give you something like
beta over n constants here right so in
that way the erasure information
controlled and and in fact this this is
if you fall if you know the differential
privacy literature this is the McSherry
table where exponential mechanism but of
course you know in statistical physics
this is the gibbs distribution and you
know the all sorts of large deviation
principles are associated to it so you
can do things with that okay but then we
run into some problems because
information theory is all good and well
you know why do we use information
theoretic concepts because we have chain
rules right so you know chain rules are
important for quantifying composition
the chain rules are handy for
quantifying composition right so for
example we have this
chain rule for provisional information
if I have so remember that I have my
data set s and and now suppose I
actually do this adaptive composition so
T rounds so by the chain rule from
mutual information this thing have you
written like this s.w.t conditioned on
everything that came before so if you
can control each of these terms and
guarantee that that's small in epsilon
and you see where you have that linear
degradation instability right the same
thing goes for goes for a ratio mutual
information you can you know just apply
chain rule to each term and then you
know collect terms rearrange the
summation get get something like this
this is so these things that compose
adaptively that's why we like mutual
information however here's an example
where all this stuff fails spectacularly
it's just utterly useless in the example
is just estimating the mean when the
data come from a density I suppose you
know I have I have
you know z1 Zn and they're iid according
to some distribution mu and then
expectation of each of these things is
equal to em I want to estimate em so you
know quick obviously you know the
empirical mean is is this right that's a
good estimator
and it's clear that okay so let's
suppose that my data are all bounded so
you actually not only do you have you
know it's a good estimator in the sense
of chebyshev it's a good estimate and
estimator in the sense of everything
right it concentrates nicely around the
true mean etc moreover if the day are
bounded so if I change one of these
points the estimate will change by no
more than 1 over n so it's clearly
stable in a very very colloquial sense
of the word however even the total
variation distance but if I were to look
at if I were to look at so what what is
if I were to look at the total variation
distance let's say between the
distribution of this empirical mean on
one data set
and another day son
different only one oh man I mean this is
these these are going to be mutually
singular
you're basically gonna get one unless
you know if if if at least one of these
elements is if the Train says differ the
Hamming distance between the two and of
course the mutual information is gonna
be large and so you're not gonna get
anywhere with this and deterministic
estimators are our building block things
for example if I were to do and this is
this is just a simplest thing but from
doing M estimation from doing M
estimation I'm I'm minimizing empirical
mean of something over some you know or
some parameter space and against the
deterministic estimate and typically
those will be atomic measures and you
know any reasonable distance between
atomic measures is is gonna max out
mutual information is even worse because
you know these things have a density and
I look at this transformation that maps
Z n to their average
that's gonna have infinite mutual
information between data any decision
so then we thought okay let's let's
let's think about this more
geometrically let's think about in terms
of distances in in our actual hypothesis
space well how much time do I have left
okay perfect
okay so so that's actually a good point
in to to introduce this this whole
transportation notion right so now let's
let's let's think about the geometry of
our of our space W
so suppose that W is
so these using just running these
markers into the ground so each of these
distributions there we go index by the
data set is an element of the space of
distributions on unlike you know
decision space now I'm gonna assume that
actually my decision space is a metric
space with a metric row and and I'm also
going to assume that in many cases let's
say the loss function L is Lipschitz
with respect to that metric for each
fixed Z right so
Susy is less than or equal to L role
this is often the case and and so then
naturally I'm led to the following thing
if so if I can guarantee that somehow
okay suppose that I fix two data sets
and SN s bar Hamming distance between
them is one and I generate WS from PS
and they'll use bar from far and then I
look at Wasserstein distance between so
I look at
so uncle D Rho R is going to be in theme
um overall joint joint distributions M
that are distributions on a Cartesian
product of L of W with itself of row
between w w prime m DW right so I'm
looking at all join distributions
okay so M
this is gonna be so the first marginal
is going to be PS and the second
marginal is going to be PS bar so I'm
looking at all couplings and I'm
minimizing you know this with respect to
all such couplings I'm looking and
looking at how how much distance between
these elements like I can have and I
would say that the algorithm is
Wasserstein stable if this thing is
small whenever the Hamming distance
between s and s bar is equal to 1 and
actually has a lot of interesting
consequences one important consequence
is that Wasserstein distances is dual
characterization
oh yeah this is also kind of in the work
with with our lien and Matt's ow and you
Kong and Sasha Rahman and so so
Wasserstein distance D ro between two
two distributions P and Q is a supreme
Amol functions F that are one Lipschitz
with respect to that metric row and it's
expected you know difference between
expected values so F I use capital F
capital F right
DP minus so if if you have an algorithm
or procedure which is Wasserstein stable
alright so so if I could say that dear
oh yes yes bar is less than epsilon is a
Hamming distance between s and s bars
one then essentially you see that the
supremum over all asses of
Rosy's rather expected value of let's
say what did I use for my loss function
L L of WS z conditioned on s - L of WS R
and Z conditioned on bar this thing is
gonna be less than L times epsilon and
so and this is actually uniform
stability and that automatically tells
you that the bias of this algorithm is
also no more than epsilon all right so
so so that's that's already a geometric
notion it doesn't really ostensibly
review with information theory but we'll
see later the information theory can be
brought in if you can establish
something called transportation
transportation cost inequality the nice
thing about this is a it satisfies
triangle inequality the Wasserstein
distance so if i can show how how do I
show stability of an algorithm or a
procedure one way I could do it is say
that oh it's close to another another
another algorithm which is actually
stable all right so then that would
actually give me a criterion for for for
deducing stability by you know what
happens a lot of times a lot of times we
have an algorithm which is good in
particular is stable but it's not
particularly tractable or you know it's
it's less tractable than we'd want it to
be case in point is something like
gradient descent alright so so let me
demand this is actually very very simple
demonstration of this case in point is
gradient descent when which is meant to
be a stochastic gradient descent is
meant to be a proxy for empirical risk
minimization because empirical risk
minimization involves you know computing
minimizing a function and as a function
is as an average of individual losses on
each training example and a lot of times
even even just doing full gradient
descent is computationally intractable
each each step requires that computing
the gradient which takes in operations
right so so we want to we start with
empirical risk minimization right so
theta hat n I don't want to cos theta
even seen on the classical mole w w hat
n
deterministic thing is a minimizer let's
say you long constrained whatever it of
this empirical loss right so and there's
an interesting result due to so there's
a paper by shell of sorts
at all premiere I think that show that
if you know if if if L is so on the
strong convexity
and Lipschitz right so here of course
the problem is constrained right here
you can't have a function which is
strongly convex and Lipschitz everywhere
but it can be on a compact set so it
means that you know W is constrained to
be some compact set of you know in Rd
erm is actually is you know Big O of 1
over N stable in usual sense it
essentially tells you that if I if I so
so let me let me indicate the data set
here you can actually show that the
distance between so again Hamming
distance is equal to 1 the distance
between these minimizer's
where is actually on the order of one
over so it is stable at so in fact it is
stable trivially in the Wasserstein
sense right because if these are two
deterministic to direct measures the
Wasserstein distance between two direct
measures is simply the distance between
the set their centers right because
that's the only way I can transport one
on to the other but it turns out that
you know but but now I mean this is how
you solve erm you know typically
intractable if n is large so you would
use their caster gradient descent right
so so stochastic gradient descent what
is it it's actually stochastic
approximation with respect to the
empirical measure so you know one way to
think about it if you have a fixed data
set you you know you sample with
replacement so you have this bag of
examples you know shake it reach in and
pull one take the gradient in that
direction this is essentially the
situation where usual stochastic
approximation thing where I want to
minimize an expected value of something
with respect to parameter and what I do
is instead of minimizing the expected
value I draw samples from my
distribution right each time and treat
that as it's an unbiased estimate the
gradient etc right so stochastic
gradient descent with something with
replacement the simply stochastic
approximation with respect to the
empirical distribution of the samples
and then you can actually show that so
right so essentially here stochastic
gradient descent it's WT plus 1 is a
projection onto my set W of WT minus ADA
and then you have gradient of L WT and
then randomly selected I T here's you
know these ITR iid I won my t iid draws
from you know uniform distribution on on
a set of indices and then you can show
using more or less stochastic
approximation theory that the expected
value
of a square distance between WT plus one
and here let's put s here again to
indicate dependence on the data set s
right so you can show that this mine is
that
is actually this is Big O of 1 over T
and so and and that actually tells me
that the the Wasserstein distance with
Euclidean norm right so you know just
usual Euclidean norm between let's say
so I as GD t steps and P erm this is
actually all one routine and and now I
can actually say something like this so
you know so I'm gonna say P SGD key
steps yes as GD he steps on a different
data set that differs in one example
triangle inequality then tells me simply
that this is less than
well it's the same thing for the other
data sent
my mic my border handwriting is
notoriously bad students complain all
the time plus essentially the distance
between the ERM solutions right so w hat
and s and w hat s bar and you know this
is this is 1 over n and these two terms
are 1 over square root T so you so you
get something like this is all of 1 over
n plus 1 over square root T
in fact I think you can actually remove
the square here all right so this
estimate okay so it's not the best you
can do for for stochastic gradient
descent with strongly convex and and
Lipschitz objectives but at least it
tells you that this is actually a very
sensible procedure if you know if you
have an algorithm which is compositional
this out obviously it's compositional
right because you know you take your
data set and you start compute and in
fact your you know your initialization
it may be even independent of the data
and you start computing in this
Markovian manner right you know so so
ww3 depends on W 2 and s W 4 depends on
W 3 and s it's a Markov it's so
conditioned on the data
it's a Markov it's a Markov chain it's
still composition there you should you
don't normally think about gradient
descent as a compositional thing it's a
black box but it really is a composition
here what we're saying is that I can
approximate it by another algorithm
which I know to be stable and in this
case just the vanilla erm and and and
then and then you see that in fact I can
I can look at the progress that that
this makes towards optimizing he steps
in fact this these terms skinnier this
one root e can be improved you know on
there's some conditions there's a soul
all work an important sampling for for
SGD and there's some under some
conditions like this 1 over T or 1 or
Atika actually be made exponential in T
so you know you can get a statement
about stability this way
not particularly ok it's not
particularly easy to do something like
this when the assumption of strong
convexity is removed so in particular
you know so the best bound we have is in
the paper by where it's been wrecked and
Yoram singer train faster generalize
better I suspect that that can be
improved simply because we have even in
the case of non convex but sufficiently
well behaved functions we have great
stochastic gradient descent is still a
Markov chain which should still have
decent convergence properties but you
know I've been unable to do anything
about that but but I can I can show one
particular way in which one can handle
well
compositions of algorithms and say
something about their Wasserstein
stability using something called the de
Bruijn comparison theorem
I don't want to give the you know the
full full background done on this on
this theorem I just want to say the
following state the following fact
okay so
so it's going to apply for apply to an
arbitrary adaptive composition so we
have so consider
yes you w-want through he it's a product
of these individual steps given and and
suppose the following
but define the following things
see s don't want to use s s s data t T
Prime
is the supremum over all let's see so
here so here if
one case would be when when t prime is
greater than
when t prime when t is greater than T
prime supremum over all tuples W T W bar
T such that W T is equal to W bar T
except everywhere except T Prime so they
may disagree in the index T Prime and
then you would look at the Wasserstein
distance with respect to a suitable
metric so you know you endow each each
each space with a metric so Wasserstein
distance between the distribution
aw
given
yeah given everything else missing the
supportively if
yeah
given WT minus 1 and GWT given W prime t
minus 1 like I said my handwriting is
awful divided by the metric between W T
and T prime here all right so what we're
doing is we're looking at the distance
so if I if I if I have two different
paths by which I could have arrived by
time T I look at I look at the
difference between the distributions and
scale it that you know look at the
contraction basically and zero otherwise
and and epsilon T would be the
Wasserstein distance between P s
see here DW T given everything and PS
bar DW T given everything so here so C's
measure 1 1 we feed the same data set
but possibly somehow to ended up with
different trajectories in the past how
would that affect the trajectory in the
future right the the the path of the
algorithm of future epsilon is compare
Epsilon's are essentially stability
steps of each of each stability
estimates for each step then you can
show that for any function on
expectation of any function Lipschitz
function on the last step of the
algorithm - this is less than or equal
to it's a sum the key from 1 to capital
T of so there's this function as
Lipschitz right so for L Lipschitz F
Lipschitz constant and then there's
going to be a matrix D I'm going to
define it T epsilon T where what is D
what is this matrix D D is the it's the
powers of
of this matrix see CT assuming of course
that this this series converges this is
called you know this is a consequence of
the so-called de Bruijn comparison
theorem and you can actually so you can
immediately show that in fact my
previous estimate for SVD was strongly
convex objectives is very loose you can
actually get something stability does
not even depend on T just you know scale
is 1 over n this is also the result in
the paper by Moore it's been and and
Yoram but but you know I just obtained
it differently I mean despite my
horrible handwriting here here the idea
is that each step of the algorithm each
each each compositional step the
stability of that is influenced by two
things how stable each of the
compositional steps by itself right so
this is this quantity right distance
between so at each stage I'm looking at
two different data sets and I'm saying
okay how if I change the data sets but
the algorithms run the same way how how
different are they but this says okay
well the thing is that you could have in
fact arrived you know by the time T you
could have let's say what stochastic
gradient descent this is actually kind
of similar to to these ideas in this
train faster generalize better paper the
two datasets differ in one element at
some point you're going to hit that that
element in which they differ so the
gradients are going to be different at
this point the gradients the gradient
updates are going to diverge from one
another they're going to drift apart
this quantifies that so if we have an
algorithm that somehow does not allow
the iterates to drift too much right so
these dependencies become weaker and
weaker and weaker and some and somehow
each each each of the steps is stable
then we can have an overall stable
algorithm but you know unfortunately
I've only been able to prove that you
know to use this non trivially for for
the case of stochastic gradient central
strongly convex and smooth objectives
and like I said probably the the
important sampling the Koch Marsh method
could probably you know be analyzed and
and can get the same conclusion
but this this at least paves the way and
this is based like I said based on the
de Bruijn comparison theorem it's not
about any item called the theorem it's a
straightforward kind of just application
of of the de Bruijn comparison theorem
to this this idea but but but you know
as far as I know if we have local
description these compositional steps
that the brush in comparison theorem is
the best tool that we have the generic
Bell generic tool we have for for
quantifying these things okay how am i
doing on time now okay five minutes is
fine um so now just wait sorry just the
notation so little D TT is the last row
of this matrix
yes that's the last row because I'm only
so in general in general though if you
could look at the function of all the
W's you would have to sum over all the
rows and all the columns but here if I
only care about the last hitter it that
name is the last last row
and so now I want to just you know I
talked about these deterministic
algorithms for quite a while and by the
way in well I don't think I'll get to
MCMC but I want to actually explain a
little bit of how this would work and
it's actually fairly fairly simple in
the case of in a case of SGD Prime in
the case of SGD what strongly convex
objectives so what happens what does
your mark of colonel look like it looks
like this if I were to be you know
really fancy and write it out at time T
given previous data it's it's an average
of the iraq deltas and the Dirac Delta
sit I miss let's suppose you know for so
as a projection of WT minus eight at
times the gradient of the loss at the
life example sitting at UWT well
so for dot here and right because that's
that's what that's what you do it
corresponds to selecting selecting a
training point at random and then going
in the direction of that gradient and
then projecting so you can actually so
how would you how would you compute the
you know the Wasserstein distance one
thing you could do is just just simply
you know simplest Wasserstein distances
and this is in fact that so we talked
about coupling this is a coupling that
more meets and Ben and and your amused
and in their paper the word coupling
didn't appear and that there really is
that what you do is you start with two
different data sets but these I tease
the one that the indices that that
select the the the training examples are
the same you so you couple to Markov
chains through the same noise it's
called synchronous coupling in that case
you can actually see that if w s t minus
w s bar T right if I if I if I know if I
know this right so the distance between
these Euclidean distance by the non
expensiveness of projections as upper
bounded well square is easier is equal
to exactly the distance between t minus
1 minus twice
let's see ADA and then you have this
that inner product with the difference
of gradients
see I write the day they couple to the
same you know noise right so minus the
gradient here minus the gradient w right
plus the difference of gradients 8 is
squared right sorry Mike my handwriting
my board handwriting in fact it just
gets worse with them
w Primus t minus 1 CI and then you can
actually see that because because of the
strong convexity and and things like
that
this can be upper bounded by 1 - there's
going to be 2 ADA
this is gonna be the strong convexity
constant plus a 2 squared M Squared if
the gradient is Lipchitz times this
right so WS t minus 1 minus WS bar t
minus 1 so you can see that by taking a
- small enough you can make sure that
this is a contraction so these terms
here are all less than 1 so that matrix
do you wanna take powers you know
essentially I'm summing a converging
geometric series and I end up with
exactly exactly the estimate and this
term here this epsilon T is actually 1
over N but Big O of 1 or n because you
know this corresponds to the case when I
have two different data sets a different
one examples so for the most part unless
I hit that one example I'm gonna have
exact coincidence but that example is
hit with probability 1 over N so you
know you get 1 over n difference there
so now I'm out of time but but the point
is that ok so I didn't get to the MCMC
of course but I think that this idea
based on kind of geometric or
Wasserstein distances is also a fruitful
way for analyzing stability of of
compositions of statistical disease
decision procedures so you know
hopefully in some you know later point
in time I you know I'll tell you more
about this you know with more refined
results you know thanks for suffering
through this
[Applause]
so the chief STD will work in the
non-smooth case I guess not but is there
any hope for analyzing for certain
methods in the school sitting Oh so-so
no some other first-order like maybe
with more than markup updates or
something like that the flow method yeah
I mean so in the case in the case of
Markov updates is just no this matrix
matrix C is you know it has a single
zeros everywhere except right below the
main diagonal so you know you could have
banded matrices and then you know you
just as long as you can arrange for you
know for this D to be you know as long
as the spectral radius of C is less than
one you're okay but of course you know
for each specific algorithm you have to
kind of you know one hope I have us to
analyze the case where where your where
your function is strongly kind of X
outside outside some ball and and and
has manageable behavior inside that ball
so perhaps you know one could do
something with that but probably some
sort of momentum based methods
let's take more questions to the break
we now have a 25 minute break and then
videos next